nossos empresário e alegria maconha ou
sacar todo dia como no mac donald's
também deixou brincando é não tem
cansaço faz mal tá não vale é que o
dólar saísse livre william é que ele nem
a reinar e pá e é e nem lá entende que
nunca fez isso e aí galera questionado
você e em recife de olinda que está novo
gabbana ou ray muitos presentes muitas
cartinhas a été de uma em cape cá que os
com carinho de sua forte recife
vanessa araújo veio uma onda
a apreensão ler um livro e se é macho
que não chegou nesta quarta hoje é o dia
de quem hoje é o dia das mães o dia da
mulher que colocou nesse mundo
o dia da mulher que amamentou e cuidou
de você e que cuidou para que você
tivesse um bom futuro
hoje é o dia dela a mulher guerreira sua
mãe merece então comecei só de 2000
apenas 1599 é só amanhã no dia das mães
assim a propaganda panache graça eu acho
engraçado quando é dia das mães
comercial estão já e tentar convencer a
gente que aquele produto vai servir para
muita gente a sua mãe precisa do melhor
a sua mãe precisa de carinho
sua mãe precisa de proteção e nem sempre
você está lá para protegê la
então dessa arma de apenas 699 reais da
sua mãe olha é muito humor o povo é de
carro pra mãe daqui é de sofá geladeira
gente eu nem tem um sofá um é que eu vou
dar uma mãe como eu tenho uma coisa que
ele não terá mãe acha o maior presente
que dei a minha mãe na minha vida foi
ensinada mexer no facebook é uma coisa
que você também deveria fazer às vezes
você pode assim hoje eu fui no shopping
com a galera o hull foi muito legal a
evento amanhã o bom filho você gostou
mãe está com saudade sabe aquelas suas
roupas que você esqueceu aqui
aquelas suas cuecas todas as cagadas já
lavei hashtag eu sair hoje com seu pai
foi bem bacana bem sup papa se
divertimos de montão com essa turminha
que é do barulho ash tag foi um bom
teste no lugar errado bem legal seu
irmão foi tentar pular de um pé de manga
para outro e caiu no chão hashtag
vírgula esta é na fila enfim filhão
estão com saudades meu bebezinho não
esquece de passar pomada naquele seu
furúnculo no ensino em si não vai mexer
no facebook tem um bate papo ela vai
perguntar se todo mundo vai ver você vai
dizer que não é só muitos problemas eu
gosto muito da minha mãe que significa
muito pra mim que a minha mãe ela sempre
cuidou de mim quando estava doente ela
ia lá e me levava em quando eu tava
triste ela ia lá e ela grava quando eu
estava feliz é ir lá e compartilhar a
felicidade comigo quando ela estava
limpa na casa chegava da escola falava
mãe tá entrando ela falava piso nessa
cerâmica limpa que eu arrebento após
perna que muita coisa linda do coração
da nossa vida que ama nossa vida até
você sujar o chão que em que não é
qualquer chão é o chão bela e ai de você
se pisar o elenco é engraçado eu quero
engraçadas e chegava em casa não sabe
como está limpa na casa chegava entrava
quando eu entrava que olhando para trás
eu tava lá minha pegada do pé sujo aí eu
voltava devagarzinho pegava o tapete
limpa que eu tinha sujado faltava pra
cima do tapete falavam mancha é e menos
de um milésimo de segundo já está no
lecce acreditava
na hora de limpar e eu respondi é claro
mãe senhora é louca que eu acho que eu
vou entrar nessa casa senhor limpando
lógico que não em não mesmo nunca
entraria nunca eu só imagino meu deus do
céu se eu tivesse entrado o la patria
apanhei muito ruim e muito né apanhar
que mereciam e eu era moleque eu merecia
apanhar michael era danado ao entanto
era pequeno eu virei especialista em sua
e de seu filme be no meio da praça e
amanhã em dois tamanhos mini e mini ramp
eu falei assim saberá faltando a senhora
minha mãe tinha técnica mãe tinha tanta
técnica apelidada de beto carreiro é
jogar os dois segundo o im
minha mãe foi a primeira pessoa que me
ensinou que havaianas pega efeito o irã
foi matheus ficar com ela falou num
corrã eu corri menor que ela mais rápido
me escondi de entrar no mundo a lei é
uma rã e que ele está no muro e só
esperou dois segundo porque assim minha
mãe chorou xingou o merey busca técnica
a minha mãe é uma idéia ela tem até um
monte de mandar gente arrumar as coisas
é a felicidade da mãe não é que as
coisas tenham mandela quer que ele não
fique e o pior é que ela sempre vence a
gente nos argumento 2 manhã roda sempre
vence a gente à minha volta mais a cama
pela manhã rumo a essa turma pra que
esse noite vou dormir de novo ela ainda
vai faltar nem pouco não que a meta vai
pagar de novo em simples para dispor
todos os conceitos assunto eu levei tudo
eu queria agradecer eu queria agradecer
a todas as mães de todos os meus fãs que
me assistem que vocês querem ou não às
vezes há uma mãe de vocês brigam porque
vocês nasce porque o xingu nos vídeo tá
certa a mãe não quer nada de mal pra
você não a mãe ela só quer o bem do
evento de olinda tinha uma mãe que falou
assim olha ela era sua fã mas ela me
apresentou agora quem assisti lá em casa
sou eu sou sua fã e é isso que eu virei
para ele e falei assim o que o senhor
acha quando faço sempre que tu rola o
ela falou rômulo já vi pedindo que eu
tenho e desgraça acontece todo dia é
novidade pra ninguém e só uma mãe uma
mãe que gosta daquele que eu faço bichos
é gratificante demais então queria
mandar um grande abraço e um beijo
muitos anos de vida todas as mães que me
assistem e em especial à minha mãe quem
me ajudou quem me deu o excesso que me
ajuda até hoje a minha mãe se ela
falasse muito isto não tem futuro não é
ninguém vai ser um mérito vai ser um
bosta e ainda ia continuar a mandar
minha mãe só porque ela é minha e martin
muito sofrimento com mais três irmãos me
criou enquanto que só vai falar pra você
se ela me chateia ela fala com o suíno
que você ninguém ela é sua mãe e mãe é
mãe não importa a idade se importar com
40 anos debaixo da casa dos pais ela
pode bater na hora que ela quiser no
espancamento fala espancar não tem
alguém aí que a mãe espanca denuncia
falou mãe eu te amo tanto mas a senhora
me espancava a cadeia não se falei
maneira da maioria das crianças ele se
você gostou do vídeo já sabe né
se tiver no facebook aquela curtida tá
no youtube daquele gostei
há no twitter daquele rtp e no facebook
também é bom que você compartilhe
marquei os seus amigos pra mais gente vê
marca sua mãe se tiver facebook fala
mamãe olha só que vive bem legal e
maneira vamos nos divertir de montão eu
queria que você comentasse aqui embaixo
uma mensagem para sua mãe não sei se ela
vai ou não mais comenta eu quero ver as
coisas que vocês querem falar com a mãe
de vocês que a primeira vez está
assistindo o vídeo e inscrever se tudo
estiver de novo vai saber
é nóis e proibiu e